well let's get the latest situation on
the ground joining me our defense and
security analyst professor michael clark
and let's talk about troop movements in
the east first shall we what do we know
about what's happening yes i mean sarah
jane the whole thing is is centered onto
very donetsk the russians have
surrounded us on three sides which
they've done some time ago and we keep
waiting for them to cut it off
completely because if you look at a map
of this size it looks as if they haven't
got really much to do to grab the rest
of luhansk but lavrov the russian
foreign minister have said they want the
whole of the donbass so they want don
jones as well which is a rather bigger
territory but even grabbing the whole of
luhansk is not as simple as it looks
when you see it on a map of this size
yeah if we zoom in closer you could just
sort of see how vast the space is in
between the two cities that doesn't
really do it justice does it and when
you think how long it took russian
troops to take mariupol what kind of job
have they got on their hands in sierra
donetsk and how are they getting on in
general because i mean this is a big
country that's the i mean ukraine's a
big country and when you actually look
at maps in a bigger scale you realize
what the distances are that we're
talking about so the ukrainians are
fighting against very done yet because
the the russians or the chechens
actually have got into one part of it to
the eastern part they grabbed a hotel
which they're using as an observation
post and a power station or power grid
area and the ukrainians are competing
for it so they're not giving up the city
and the ukrainians have got um south
west of lichishants they've got about
four brigades that's about twenty
thousand troops in this general area
that's a that's quite a big force and
that force is supplying across the river
the sovereignty don its river the the
bridges are all down one way or another
but they're getting supplies into the
city so they're able to supply it
because they've got those troops there
if they get under pressure the question
that they have to ask themselves is do
they fall back on slaviant and
kramertosk those are the two cities that
are the key to the rest of the donbass
so if uh
if lavrov really means that they want
the whole of the donbass they have to
take slovakians and kramatorsk and in
front of those two cities is high ground
and that matters even these days high
ground matters in battles so the
ukrainians do have the choice to give up
this territory if they have to and fall
back on slavic ants and cremators now
what the russians would like to do is
that they took popassna uh some time ago
a couple of weeks ago and they've very
slowly started to move north they took
lyman over the weekend that was a big a
big uh
plus for them and they've started to
move south but they've still got to
cross the river what of course they
would like to do is finish off in severe
dynetsk and get behind the ukrainians
here these four brigades that are uh
west of the of the river but they won't
do this quickly those distances that's
about 45 miles between lyman and
popasner and at the moment the russians
are only making you know one and a half
to two miles of advance on a good day
sometimes not nothing at all so the
ukrainians are not going to find
themselves overnight surrounded they've
got time to think about what to do and
not least the road from bakmut to
lishyshansk that road it's uh if the if
you're a tourist you'll know it as the
t-1302 but that road and another one
slightly to the north of it the russians
actually occupied that road for a while
last week the ukrainians took it back so
that road is now in ukraine's hands and
it might have been a tourist road at one
time but it's a vital supply line now
now it's within artillery range of
russian forces so it's a bit of a
thunder run going up and down it one
would guess but as long as that road
stays open the ukrainians have got
choices that they can make so then they
they do risk being surrounded it's not
going to happen overnight they have time
to think about it and they are not going
to make it easy for the russians to
close this little pocket which when you
look on a big map looks easy okay
professor michael clark um
interesting to hear your perspective of
what's going on in the ground as you
said as you zoom in
we get a bigger picture if you see what
i mean thank you very much for the
moment more from professor michael clark
throughout the program